un cereal milenario había caído en el
olvido y está volviendo al menú de los
restaurantes en India
el mijo una semilla originaria de Asia
vuelve a hacer su aparición gracias a
chef como van chica batía inspirada por
su abuela que solía cocinar platos a
base de mijo
creo que el mijo es el sustituto
perfecto de la arena de trigo por
ejemplo es un carbohidrato lento uno se
siente lleno durante más tiempo comiendo
raciones más pequeñas además el mejor le
da un sabor original al plato que no le
da el trigo como pastas sin gluten
galletas o pan el mijo puede consumirse
de muchas formas olvidado durante siglos
eclipsado por el arroz y el trigo este
cereal está de vuelta gracias a un
puñado de agricultores indios
en el sur del país a más de mil
kilómetros de Nueva Delhi en el estado
de talangana
es considerado un pionero
estos cultivos tienen dos meses y la
cosecha se podrá hacer en unos 100 días
conocido como el señor mijo ferry
introdujo ese cereal ancestral en sus
campos hace 15 años desde entonces ha
viajado por todo el país ha conocido y
formado a 10.000 agricultores indios
para convencerlos de que vuelvan a
cultivar este cereal
mejor el viento y no se partan por la
mitad
yo también las malas hierbas que hay
alrededor
pero frente a la competencia del arroz
el trigo o la caña de azúcar cuyos
precios están regulados por el estado no
siempre es fácil convencer a los
agricultores de las ventajas del mijo es
difícil convencerlos de que planten un
cultivo y no otro la mayoría de los
agricultores de acá no quieren
escucharnos la mayoría cultiva caña de
azúcar con la diferencia de que un
Cañaveral necesita 120 veces más agua
que el mijo para crecer más agua y más
cuidados por repetimos constantemente
que el mijo alcanza la madurez en Sólo
dos o tres meses sobre todo requiere
poco mantenimiento Y para terminar de
convencerlos les aconsejo que empiecen
con este tipo de mijo el sorgo y que lo
siempre en alrededor de sus plantaciones
o lo combinen con otros cultivos otro
obstáculo Es la falta de
infraestructuras para procesar el mijo
para su gente y consumo ver instaló esta
unidad en medio de las tierras de
cultivo ahora 300 agricultores pueden
utilizarla para limpiar sus cosechas
les explicamos que si no pasan por esta
etapa no obtendrán un buen precio cuando
vendan pero una vez procesado les
pagarán el doble por el mismo y si lo
transforman en un producto de consumo
directo el precio puede multiplicarse
por 4 lo que es mucho más rentable
bueno es el único que Apuesta por este
cereal la comunidad científica considera
que el mijo es el cereal del futuro en
los suburbios de heider bat el Instituto
internacional de investigación de
cultivos para las zonas tropicales
semiáridas se extiende a lo largo de 13
kilómetros cuadrados
el campus cuenta con tierras de cultivo
decenas De laboratorios y sobre todo el
mayor banco de semillas del mundo
el profesor cultive zinc es el Custodio
de 79.000 variedades de mijo conservadas
Entre cuatro y menos 20 grados
centígrados esta variedad fue almacenada
aquí en 1978
el mijo se caracteriza por ser más
resistente a las olas de calor que
cualquier otro cereal
es naturalmente resistente a las
variaciones climáticas
por ejemplo el mijo de perla puede
crecer fácilmente en climas muy cálidos
es difícil ahora el cambio climático
parece Inevitable podemos apostar que el
mijo se verá mucho menos afectado que
los otros cultivos
empezando porque necesita mucha menos
agua para crecer si lo comparamos con el
arroz el trigo o el maíz
todos los años las sequías y las
inundaciones retrasan las cosechas de
trigo y arroz el mijo En cambio es capaz
de crecer en tierras agrícolas
degradadas y secas y su secreto reside
en los genes de estas semillas que han
sido almacenadas durante décadas y son
analizadas periódicamente
todas estas semillas son el resultado de
miles o incluso millones de años de
evolución desde que las especies
salvajes se convirtieron en plantas
es probable que todos estos mijos hayan
heredado genes que les permiten ser
naturalmente resistentes a ciertas
enfermedades o insectos
este centro de investigación creado en
los años 70 también tiene la misión de
ayudar a cientos de millones de
agricultores de todo el mundo a luchar
contra el hambre y el cambio climático
miren no son hermosas
para Jacqueline directora del instituto
el mismo podría desempeñar un papel
clave para garantizar la seguridad
alimentaria de un país por un lado está
la obesidad por otro las poblaciones que
mueren de hambre y en el medio está la
desnutrición
el mijo puede resolver todos estos
problemas es bueno para la salud tiene
muchos nutrientes y no tiene gluten
es perfecto para la exportación
India convenció a las Naciones Unidas de
declarar 2023 como año Internacional del
mijo el país es el primer productor
mundial con 15 millones de toneladas
anuales
ahora que la guerra en Ucrania ha
desestabilizado el mercado mundial de
cereales India podría posicionarse como
alternativa si consigue reactivar el
sector del mijo a largo plazo